it's okay i'm surprised i'm a comedian
too
uh we'll get through this together be a
team effort
i uh i was walking on the street
recently we're not that different you
and i
and uh a black guy with a mohawk was
coming down the street this way
complimented a white guy with a mohawk
going the other way yeah
so i made a wish
[Laughter]
like i know our miracles work i've been
around
it's probably one of the most
influential moments in my life right up
there with when i realized
any pizza can be a personal one if you
cry while you eat it
sorry to go political that's how i
feel
this isn't easy for me to say but i do
have some white
friends it happens
it's kind of unavoidable in this economy
sometimes i'll make a mistake though
when one of my white friends apologizes
to me
i'll assume it's for imperialism on some
level
i know it's totally my issue
but it does lead to some weird
situations
like recently one of these so-called
friends returned a dvd to me late
and she was like hey aparna here's your
copy of hotel for dogs sorry about the
delay
and then i was just like and
[Music]
and she was like i'm pretty sure it's
just the dvd
and i was like no remember your people
my people
and she was like this again
and i was like history's wounds never
heal
she was like where did a yogurt land
and i was like it used to be my
yogurtland
[Applause]
and she was like that's the wrong kind
of indian
i consider myself a good person like if
someone sneezes once in public i'll step
up to bat
like i'll give them the gaze in tight or
go with jesus
be your best buddha whatever i believe
in that day
but if someone sneezes three or more
times
it's like get your life together
what is going on with you
get on webmd get some answers
carry your weight in society
i realize i have kind of an innocent
vibe and sometimes i'll come up here and
i'll spout my opinions
and someone in the audience will
inevitably be like boy
she sure has a lot to say considering
what she looks like
and that's fine i own a mirror i'm on
your side
but i just want to assure you i've
experienced my share of real life like
i've had orange juice after brushing my
teeth
i get it i get what you're going through
here are a few examples of how i've
learned my street cred
one time i saw this on the sidewalk
fresh pile of dog poop
with a used condom on top of it
i know i was there
at which point i invented a new game
called
too much information
not enough
there are no winners in that game you're
right
you just start an instagram account and
you keep it moving
put it on the internet where it counts
another time i was hanging out in an
alley just something i do for fun
and i saw a trash can
thrown out in a garbage bag
sure i'll repeat that trash can thrown
out in a garbage bag
and i was just like whoa the student has
become the master